y la prevención del cáncer de pulmón
incluye medidas que se pueden tomar para
reducir la probabilidad de desarrollar
cáncer lo más importante que puede hacer
para prevenir el cáncer de pulmón es no
comenzar a fumar o dejar de hacerlo si
lo hace
evite inhalar el humo de otros
haga pruebas para verificar si en su
casa hay radón un conocido agente
cancerígeno evite exponerse a químicos
cancerígenos en el trabajo mantenga un
peso saludable porque el sobrepeso puede
causar que en el cuerpo circulen niveles
más altos de ciertas hormonas que pueden
estimular el crecimiento del cáncer siga
una dieta llena de frutas y vegetales
que contienen sustancias que pueden
ayudarle a reducir el riesgo de cáncer y
controlar su peso
ejercítese regularmente lo que le
ayudará a controlar su peso y reducir el
riesgo de cáncer gracias a su influencia
positiva en sus niveles hormonales y en
su sistema inmunológico asegúrese de
hablar con su médico sobre formas para
reducir su riesgo de padecer cáncer de
pulmón